a moment of happiness and play amid the
destruction they've witnessed
children now live in a camp in other
Yaman in Southeastern turkey and are
being helped by volunteers
we came here to provide psychological
first aid to the children and to help
them return to the normality of life our
aim is to make the children laugh
because we say if one child laughs the
whole world laughs
more than 5 000 people live here
providing food water and shelter for
them has been a combined effort mahmet
is a businessman who came to help
this is a part of our country we know
they need both physical and financial
help we came from 1 200 kilometers away
we've been here for eight days we live
like them we eat like them we sleep in
our cars and Tents
among the tents that make up this Camp
they burn whatever they can to keep warm
in the freezing temperatures and they're
grateful for the help they've received
very big areas affected a lot is needed
and we need everyone's support from
across the country people are helping
children are breaking their piggy banks
and giving us money some have a little
money but they buy medicine and send it
to us
he shows us his tent some have heating
some don't he says some have mattresses
some don't
across the city another group of
volunteers has opened a pharmacy they
travel from Istanbul more than 1 200
kilometers away
I took annual leave to come here we
bought some medicine ourselves some were
donated to us
This Disaster has shown how people of
this country are not only United in
their grief but also their determination
to help each other
rescue operations are now shifting to
cleaning up the city and attention has
turned to those in need it's a challenge
that will remain for the foreseeable
future but people across the country are
helping in the effort Assad Al Jazeera
at the Yemen Southern turkey